my name is Peter Santaniello and I make
videos around the world but for the
first time I'm showing my home country
America in this video series my
Ukrainian wife and I travel through
Northern California to places most
foreigners and even Americans don't know
about we will show you USA culture
through the combination of an outsider's
and a locals perspective
join us on a road trip through a very
diverse often misunderstood and
stunningly beautiful land it's really
cool when you come back to your country
after being gone for a long time yes
famous recce famous this is the brekkie
I do pretty much every day of my life
three eggs put these guys over some
bread cheese and then this is what makes
it this is what makes it the avocado
nice buttery soft rich tasty California
avocados but that's not it it'll pepper
going on here salt and then this is what
I miss so much about home is salsa do
that and that's the bracket full protein
I don't eat lunch usually so I guess we
through most of the day another
interesting observation about the u.s.
is everything he's got some sort of
story
so this bread for example is Dave killer
bread Dave went to prison Dave started
over in life Dave started a bread
company when he came out now Dave's a
hero at least that's the story there's
probably another story behind that too
you are saying this nah nah you feel
like the u.s. is a place for second
chances like if you mess up you can
figure it out again right yeah does it
work in Ukraine specifically but well if
you are in that kind of story already
you're basically saying
it's done or maybe maybe it's like some
big corporation just made up a story
about Dave you're buying it you guys
American CHD there is somebody in
Ukraine let's say always just the former
prisoner on gigantically right we want
to give Dave dad a chance here yeah I'm
sure
so foreigner can always see something
that a local can't see and a local can
see something a foreigner will never
know like taxes I was telling her about
the differences of taxes in Nevada in
California how they're totally different
you never see that as a as a tourist
where are we going
and old gold mining area where they used
to mine gold out of the hills here
I remember that waiting for the school
bus at the end and if you miss the
school bus you're screwed
mom's pissed you're in trouble and I
think it teaches now looking back on it
I think it teaches time management like
don't be late don't be late for the bus
and I gotta say it is so much different
than your up so much different right
like just the feel of the place the
culture how things are laid out
there is that serious distrust here
don't you find that towards government
like people I don't think I don't think
you can feel it yeah but well in the but
it's true like there's just this feeling
like government you got to watch them
because they'll screw you over and you
don't trust them for the most part
that's what I feel here it's not like in
Ukraine they trust the government either
right there's different definitely a
difference because I remember when I
first watched some American news yeah
look at the time and Tom just became a
president and
just the national years worst in Trump
like you know saying all this words on
the TV and in Ukraine you will not see
it the normal useful never cheat on the
President or some people that work for
the government so it was really funny
like the real freedom of the speech
that's right
well it also mainstream news has turned
into sort of like an opinion format
where every journalist not everyone but
a lot of the mainstream journalists are
just speaking their opinions right
it's a lot of it's just gotten really
immature too like he said that she said
that and I don't feel good about that
yeah it's a bit ridiculous the river is
down because well it doesn't rain here
it doesn't rain here pretty much from
May April May until November
so all the rain in California comes in
the winter and what's interesting down
here babe is it's everything's green
here in the winter and in the summer
it's brown
[Applause]
fyz rental cars
you know they sell these this is where
they were blasting the sides of the
mountains and looking for gold
so just peeling away the size of the
mountains way up there diggings trail
that's beautiful
see here's the wildlife black bear
Bobcat even Hawk deer blue jay mule deer
mountain lion those things are scary
seriously you do not want a mountain
lion in front of you don't even know
what these are called I think they're
some sort of water cannon so high
pressured water would come through them
you can see the pipe there and then just
shoot out into the mountain and that's
why the side of the mountains peeled
away because they just peel it away and
then extract the gold from the stone so
this whole region in the Sierra Nevada
foothills this was where the Gold Rush
happened this is what funded the mass
migration of people to the western
United States this is what built
San Francisco this is what made a lot of
people rich this is what started Levi's
jeans
Levi's was it wasn't just the gold that
was making people money it was the
companies providing to those you know
out in the mines or wherever and so
Levi's was born and all these other
companies were born there's a little old
mining town down this dirt road if my
memory sends me correct
go check that out North bloomfield
school this is north
[Music]
nonno checked out this sign here take a
look wild bear may be present avoid
contact
don't we're just walking around
beautiful in here yeah there's a little
slip there okay okay so we're just we're
just parked out we're just walking here
and we'll leave in five minutes so we
need to pay for that if you're here for
more than 10 or 15 minutes you get paid
okay we'll be here for 14 thank you
though we're going all the way to the
coast today okay yeah it's all left yep
at the top of the hill and the pavement
ends turn to left
thank you thank you thanks so much
that's another observation about the US
as people are very proud in telling you
directions okay okay especially in New
York New York's that way they'll compete
over telling you the best route to get
to a place sort of looks like a hipster
barber shop right not too far off
old saloon looks like a pharmacy
it's really bare bear poop bear poop
it's a squirrel or something here it is
from above world's greatest hydraulic
mining operation this is how it was
happening here high pressured water
ripping apart the mountain chunks of
gold falling away this was wild here
this was brothels gunfights
crazy and they actually had the the
legal system and the whereabouts to be
able to shut down this ecological
disaster in 1884 I'm just gonna make a
little world observation here I was just
in Mariupol Ukraine and their operation
there is unbelievable it exists actually
made a video on it it's unbelievable it
exists in 2019 and they have this
massive mountain of debris or slack
right in right next to the water
leeching into it these factors just
spewing all this hell into the air and
it's still going on look every country
has its strength in weakness I'm not
here to bash on Ukraine I say so many
things good things about Ukraine but
environment and acknowledgement of
ecology is really camping is a big thing
campgrounds are a big thing this one's
pretty empty right now
but it's pretty highly regulated if you
want to rip off and do your own thing
way in the woods then you can but if you
want to stay like in a more controlled
environment there are these places
campgrounds in the national parks
there's little but here's something
interesting that's $35 to put your tent
up right in San Francisco which we're
gonna see in a couple days it's free to
put your tent up on the street so go
figure that one out but I do think it's
good that this stuff's regulated because
if the masses are gonna come into the
into the woods then keep them somewhat
together keep it organized keep it clean
and so the nature is pretty well
preserved up in these carts no trash
quite nice this is a postman
more of those monster trucks that you
love you love the big pickups Central
Valley and it's not all beaches and
mountains this state whole Center is
where most I'd say majority of the the
fruits and vegetables for the whole
country are grown it's not a pretty
place for the most part it's hot
skies are blown out nothing really here
towns are uninspiring depressing but you
see a lot of that imagining you you
moved to America you married that great
guy snake snake like snake I'm sure he
would have married you and he moves you
out here
what's so funny
it's the RV of the frigate bird serious
Walter White Jesse Pinkman
[Music]
we're getting closer to the coast couple
hours from the California coast and this
area is very remote cell phone coverage
doesn't work in so many places
[Music]
whiteness is the ocean
look in front of you
Wow
oh and that that's their right so -
yeah that's all oh Sh
end of the road so he dissected all of
California and so cool like this last
two hours it was 100 degrees like 38
Celsius now it's like 65 and much cooler
the ocean is is cold that comes the
current is the Humboldt Current
comes down from Alaska and so it keeps
the coastline cool and often there's a
lot of fog here when the interior of
California gets super hot and then this
cold water and this cold air clashes it
creases fog right on the coast but we're
lucky no fog watch the poison oak bed
there's this plants I'll show you
there's this plant called poison oak
that's nasty nasty stuff here it is the
start of our coastal trip we're just
gonna go south from here for the next
few days San Francisco tomorrow night
first night on the coast walala north of
San Francisco a couple hours and here's
our place
go ahead through her walk down the
stairs I think this is our place gets
that one on the end yes
go to the end yeah yeah some cool style
going on so this is an Airbnb look at
the bedroom nice place she's got some
cool style going on yeah this guy has
some soul cool roadtrip cool diversity
cool different zones of the state to
seeing pine trees deciduous trees palm
trees desert farmland coast mountains
that's what's cool about California and
living abroad it's like there's pros and
cons definitely pros and cons and while
I love the abroad it's always good to
come back to your country go down memory
lane I love it although it's all
interesting there's one look at
[Music]
supposed to be a fortune it's a Russian
settlement on the California coast miss
Italia Ukrainian flag fortress wall
[Applause]
pelicans and the sound of the fog are
here that sound
[Applause]